I think over the last half-century you
have had a growth in the sense to which
people are interconnected across borders
and so you can think of the
environmental movement where being a
Canadian or an American or someone from
China or someone from Ghana is not very
important because the issues that are
being confronted are so big that we
really have to reimagine ourselves as
citizens of the earth those kind of
things are incredibly important for some
of the big challenges that are facing us
into the future especially around the
environment but for many of the day to
day things that really impact people
whether they have a job whether their
kids are going to a good school whether
the neighborhood is safe those kind of
things
citizenship in a traditional
nation-state formulation remains really
really important because those global
citizens in other countries are not
going to help me change my schools if I
don't like my schools and so we're at
this moment I think where global
citizenship and the sense of being
connected to other people is really
increasing but for so many things in our
everyday lives your national citizenship
matters so much more and I think the
best indication of this is for people
who don't have that national citizenship
and therefore are always at the risk of
deportation and exclusion so in the
United States context for example if you
are a permanent resident of the United
States you have legal papers you're
allowed to be living in the United
States and you commit a crime that is
within sort of a range of different
crimes of which you could be deportable
which includes some what some people
might consider minor drug offenses you
will be deported and even if you came to
the United States at the age of two and
you speak English and you've gone
through the entire school system you
will be sent back to the country of your
parents or your your country of
citizenship and so you can imagine that
to say that global citizenship is alive
and well means nothing in that context
when you are being excluded from a
country because you don't have the right
legal status